Hello friends today we're checking out
the brand new Apple watch series 9 brand
new Apple watch Ultra 2. if you guys are
new to my channel hi I'm Justine and I'm
obsessed with apple and all things
technology and the Apple watch is one of
my favorite pieces of tech obviously
next to the iPhone but I'm so excited to
show you guys this today the one thing
I'm excited because they came out with a
new pink color to of course match the
new pink iPhone 15. now technically
speaking there's not a lot of huge
upgrades from the previous version but
what is really exciting is Apple has
managed to make the new Apple watch the
first product in their entire lineup to
be 100 carbon neutral which is a huge
feat I think this is super exciting and
I love what apple is doing to help
further the environmental initiative
they promised by 2030 that their entire
product lineup will be carbon neutral
and here it is let's unbox this
packaging is also special they've
managed to make the packaging a little
bit smaller which is one of the ways
that they're able to reduce the carbon
footprint because they're able to put
more of these boxes on a palette and
they've switched up the way that they're
actually shipping the products and
they're taking them by ocean instead of
by air and there's so many small things
that they have done there's now these
new logos on the carbon neutral products
I actually did an interview that does a
more Deep dive into all of the
environmental things that apple is doing
if you guys want to check that out it's
a great interview with apple exec's Lisa
and John so be sure to watch that after
you check this out I love unboxing Apple
watches it's such a magical experience I
don't think we give enough credit
sometimes to the packaging team you guys
really know how to do it like this is so
cool so you've got our Apple watch and
the new sport Loop band they have an
entire lineup of Apple watch bands now
that are completely carbon neutral
they're using all sorts of recycled
Fabrics old recycled watches especially
these ones from Nike they've got these
little specks in it a lot of the threads
in the sport Loop they've reused from
previous versions and it's amazing all
of the small little things that are
making such a huge difference
oh it's so great since I've been wearing
the Apple watch Ultra these tiny smaller
41 millimeter it's gonna feel so small
and dainty on my wrist I can't wait to
wear it I'm loving these new woven
cables
nice little pink color it's so great
oh this looks so good I'm wearing this
Apple watch Ultra for so long it's wild
how much smaller this is especially on
my small wrist now this is the new Nike
watch band this is also using recyclable
materials I love the Nike bands they're
some of my favorite
[Music]
so this is the stainless steel Apple
Watch series 9 and check out the modern
Buckle this is the new fine woven Apple
watch band oh that's a nice fit I really
like this it's really pretty the fine
woven kind of feels like a soft felt
like a fabricy kind of feel it's really
nice and I'm not sure if it's on the
same level as leather but it's kind of
in its own new category and I really
like it so now we're going to test out
the new feature the pinch to select
double tap it's it's pinch it's a pinch
double tap is here so basically you just
lift your arm up and you pinch your
fingers together just like so and right
now I'm scrolling through all of my home
feed stack and this is also great if I
get a phone call because I can just lift
my arm up check to see if I want to
answer double tap and I'll answer the
call okay I've answered oh we've got a
little bit of an echo now I'm gonna hang
up on you
[Music]
and there we go
today we have the Apple watch Ultra
Series two two just two Apple watch no
series
love this thing so much the first
version is absolutely incredible it
honestly has been so life-changing for
me so I can't wait to check out the
second version now I'm not gonna lie
there's not a lot of huge upgrades from
the Apple watch Ultra to the two so I do
feel like if you have the first version
there's probably not a really huge
reason to upgrade to the two but if you
don't have one yet let me tell you this
thing is absolutely Perfection so let's
unbox and check it out
[Music]
so here's the Apple watch and we have
the new Trail Loop they also came out
with a new orange Ocean band last year
the main one they featured was the
yellow so I'm definitely gonna have to
order that orange one for my next dive
trip
and here it is
now to look at both of these side by
side there really isn't much of a
physical difference to be honest with
you I don't even think that I could tell
the difference if they were sitting next
to each other
[Music]
the only difference is my Apple watch
Ultra has been through some things so
there looks like there's a little uh no
it's the same the amount of places and
things that this has been through it
looks almost perfectly brand new so
these do definitely hold up well new
braided cable charger now with the Apple
watch Ultra first came out I thought wow
this is really cool these people are
doing all these adventurous things like
hiking and Diving I'm never gonna do
that well I said in the review that I
wanted to review the Apple watch as a
dive computer and it took me a while
I've been diving for about three months
now and I'm so obsessed if it wasn't for
the Apple watch Ultra and the oceanic
Plus app making diving so accessible it
would have never been something that I
ever considered as someone who was
terrified my biggest fear was going
underwater I kid you not barely could
even swim so now I'm trying to figure
out how I can dive at least once or
twice a month thankfully I live in
California so the ocean is quite close
so it's a little bit easier but it's
definitely not an easy Hobby to do often
so it only makes sense that we go for a
dive and take the Apple watch Ultra 2
with me this is also pretty exciting
because the makers of the oceanic Plus
app also came out with the dive housing
for the iPhone so the entire time that
we're going to be underwater we're going
to be filming it with a new iPhone 15
Pro I can't wait
[Music]
thank you